تتجه الانظار في جوله الاعاده الانتخاب
رئيس لتركيا الى جيل الشباب او كما يقال
له جيل زيت هؤلاء معروف بانهم يصوتون
ويريدون ان يصوتوا لكم نحن الان في بشكتاش
ميدان التي تعتبر معقل المعارضه التركيه
الشباب الذين التقيناهم هنا يقولون نريد
التغيير بعضهم ممن عمره 20 عاما لم يعرف
سوى حكومه اردوغان والحكومات التي كان هو
رئيس للجمهوريه فيها بعضهم ليس يعني لديه
راي سلبي باردوغان ولكن بكل بساطه يريد
التغيير يريد المزيد من الحريه وايضا
الديمقراطيه
من ستنتخب ولماذا
ساصوت لصالحك لانني اجد افكاري متعلقه
بالحقوق والعداله تتناسب مع كل دشدار
اوغلو راى ايضا ان هناك استقطابا شديدا
داخل البلاد ولا استطيع
تحمل هذا الوضع
ما بالخطاب العنصري واخراج اصرار المعارض
على اخراج اللاجئين السوريين فورا هل انت
مع ذلك
ياباندا اوروبا قال سبيل المثال يوجد
اترككم في المانيا وربما يوجد سوريون في
تركيا لكنهم يجب ان يكونوا تحت الرقابه اذ
لم تبسط السيطره تنكسر الديمقراطيه ويكون
هناك سوريون اكثر من الاتراك سيكون هناك
تعقيدات لان هؤلاء اناس من ثقافات مختلفه
هناك اناس لديهم ثقافات مختلفه في بلدان
مختلفه لكنها ليست مشكله لانهم يفعلون ذلك
بطريقه منتظمه يمكن للسوريين والافغان
والباكستانيين الاذكياء الذين يساعدون
بلدنا البقاء في بلدنا لكنني اؤيد ترحيل
الباقين لمن ستصوت اليوم
كعادتي سادعم رئيسنا رجب طيب
اردوغانجا لم اصوت لحزب الشعبي الجمهوري
من قبل لكن من اجل مستقبل بلدنا من اجل
مستقبل شبابنا سادعم الشعب الجمهوري لياتي
السلام للبلاد لتاتي الاخوه لهذا السبب
ساصوت لحزب الشعب الجمهوري
لماذا ستصوت ل رجب طيب اردوغان
ادعم رئيسنا رجب طيب اردوغان على خدماته
واعماله التي يراها الجميع لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات